reading for pleasure is at an all-time
low in the United States a recent
government report revealed Americans
read for fun about 17 minutes each day
between 2003 and 2007 teen in percentage
of Americans indulging in leisure
reading on any given day dropped by
nearly 30 percent CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson is here
with a unique program that brings
reading to unexpected places Dana good
morning good morning we always say we
don't have enough time right well one
solution to our short time or even short
attention spans short stories they are
low commitment high gratitude and still
can transport us to far-flung places a
beautiful aeroplane with a pointed nose
my mini fresh and fragrant mistress it's
called lift every voice and sing in a
corner of the South Philadelphia free
library there's now a vending machine
for literature think of it as tales to
go it's a little old but it's a classic
story it sounds pretty cool to me with
the press of a button users select a
story that takes either one three or
five minutes to read within seconds the
cylinder spits out a modern-day papyrus
scroll what I love about this project is
that it gives us something a little bit
old a piece of paper to have that
tactile moment and rune irken helped
bring the kiosks to the Philadelphia
library it uses a really interesting new
technology the kind of ATM machine of
short stories to make it delightful and
joyful at the same time what's old is
new again yeah exactly in an effort to
promote literacy Philadelphia is one of
four American cities installing the
short story ATMs in public libraries
there are 35 dispensers in various
locations across North America and 180
worldwide any minute that you can spend
engaging with the written word is
advancing literacy and if it brings joy
just for that minute or five minutes
that's great
this wada vivre comes courtesy of French
company short edition which makes the
machines and manages a catalogue of more
than 100,000 stories come cheap Oh sheep
the certain amount of piece the tails
vary in tone and style I felt real dread
which resembled all things being equal
that they could that's pretty sad they
are free and guilt-free some people
would say oh no this is bad it's paper
but this isn't no so the paper is all
environmentally friendly the ink is
biodegradable so it's environmentally
conscious and and certainly recyclable
film director Francis Ford Coppola is
the Godfather of short story ATMs in
2016 he brought the first American
dispenser to his cafe in San Francisco I
loved the idea of a vending machine
dispensing machine that doesn't dispense
potato chips or beer or coffee for money
but gives you art oh this is from
William Shakespeare I was totally in the
dark
first I bumped into my bed then I bumped
into my closet
in a constant and instant world filled
with transitory and transactional
interactions these stories transport us
if only for a minute and if you want
your own short story to come out of the
ATMs you may soon get your chance
in September the Public Library
Association will launch a national
writing contest to encourage budding
authors and amateurs to add their voices
to the Despenser's such a great idea
it really is it's this little piece of
paper but it just brightens your day
it's a little quick smile and gets us
off our phones for just a moment we need
one here at CBS I think it didn't offer
one but we'll put in the request and we
could have a local writing contest I
would win John do ya expectation is
lower no no no thanks Dana